former police chiefs working at the
birthplace at the atomic bomb but their
careers on the line when the suspected
nuclear secrets were at risk
Steve Doren and Glenn WAP started
working at New Mexico's Los Alamos
National Laboratory in 2002 while
investigating a massive theft ring
they became concerned about the safety
of the country's nuclear information
they were fired before they could finish
their investigation host Alex Ferrer has
the story in tonight's episode of the
CBS series whistleblower that was a gas
of what I was seeing
here's a place that deals with the most
powerful weapon on the face of the earth
that can destroy hundreds of thousands
of people and it was like they were
manufacturing firecrackers it was
dangerous from the beginning while
salamis National Laboratory is the
birthplace of the atomic bomb and home
to some of the deadliest secrets in the
world I was a chief investigator at the
Los Alamos National Laboratory in 2002
Glenn Wald and Steve Durham both former
police chiefs were brought in to Los
Alamos to help bolster security after a
series of embarrassing and dangerous
lapses two hard drives containing the
most secret nuclear weapon information
in the world including United States and
Russia was lost today are located three
weeks later they were found behind a
Xerox machine and wiped clean of any
fingerprints right from the get-go
both investigators could see something
was terribly wrong when you deal with
the most dangerous weapon on the face of
the earth
there should be more security they met
with resistance when they tried to dig
deeper they were sweeping all of these
different thefts under the rug of a
professional investigator and all I
wanted to do was do my job and I was
being blocked but Glenn and Steve
investigated anyway and uncovered a
massive theft ring at the lab what are
the biggest things that were stolen from
there
crazy things like a forklift somebody
just drove it off it was gone some other
items like lockpicks computers and
surveillance equipment really caught
their eye
we're up to our neck and possible
espionage it got serious and dangerous
very quickly my greatest fear was that
the nuclear secrets of the United States
of America would walk out the front door
of the lab right into the hands of our
enemies
they took extreme measures to protect
their findings the trap door is located
in the closet and so what would you keep
in here documents that I took from the
lab for safekeeping that so they
wouldn't disappear but before they could
finish investigating they were fired and
so what reason did they get for fired I
didn't fit they refused to go quietly we
were upset that the students gonna go on
the Jeopardy the National seekers are
gonna go on and so quite frankly almost
in a now ii said no go fight they risked
everything so the truth could come out I
feared for my family I lost almost
everything I couldn't pay my bills I
lost my home my name is Glenn Walt I'm
Steve Doren and I am the whistleblower
and I'm a whistleblower stories are so
fascinating though Steve Dorn and Glenn
Wolf's investigation did not uncover any
evidence of espionage at the lab their
findings led to two lab employees
serving time in federal prison after
pleading guilty to charges of mail fraud
and conspiracy Doorn and wealth also
testified before an outraged Congress
Congress demanded a change in leadership
at the lab the stories you're right are
so fascinating but I love Alex's
delivery they refuse to go quietly I
want to know what's in that trapdoor
exactly so it's a good tease
whistleblower airs tonight at 9:00 8:00
central right here
yes